all right everybody happy weekend we are
going to play five questions for Evan
Nina okay so this is a further moment
saying Nina doesn't really even know
what we're doing here's what we're going
to do I pulled up this list of 200
questions to get to know somebody and
I'm going to pick five to ask you you're
going to pick time to ask me we'll go
one at a time no but the other person I
think one for you you pick one for me
okay ready your question is let's see
what's your favorite piece of piece of
clothing that you own or have owned one
of the dress from BCBG very elegant okay
that was amazing when I'm thoughtful
that was a very detailed building came I
had some comedy okay find a question for
me we do this five times a night we got
a fiction section what song have you
completely memorized the most memorable
one was this Chinese song I don't
remember it now anymore but nah this
Chinese song that I want to impress Nina
and I wasn't one of her favorite songs
and so I had a friend of mine right out
how about how it would sound in English
and then and then I would memorize it I
did what I was saying and then and then
I had Dina play it in the car
randomly it came on randomly and then I
just started singing singing dinner do
you remember any of it cheap one more
bean siga hoping continued high doping
she y'all going
but being neither John Jarvis Daugherty
New York justice engine Charlene your
Eastern sometime sorry
soon y'all gon change in love could I
make it up now that was pretty good come
on that's like three years you have to
sing it at our wedding I was forced to
next question
what job would you be terrible at can
you keep asking another question no
ancient question since Jessica I've
never done a job that was really bad
maybe even done enough jobs
how about a bonus clown I think you fear
most guys will be really bad at making
people knew it would be really bad clown
uh yeah maybe a bad time okay okay okay
come on okay good
my I answered your question for you if
you're going to go next okay - we gotta
get to college come on this game what
would your cricket room looks like might
perfect room look like a perfect room a
perfect room would have my youtube
channel playing with TV with Bailey with
with second by ii updates and comments
it would have this awesome ice cream
machine that'd be like no calorie ice
cream on soft serve orange swirl oh my
god and then would have all sorts of
toppings that were also low-calorie no
calorie toppings that i could include
with it there would be a big picture of
Nina somewhere in there
okay right important I feel like a
beanbag is important what else would I
need to happen need to have my video
camera ready to go I think like one of
those like each screen monitors you know
like a computer with like eight monitors
that you have different things on them
okay pretty cool
infinity pool that you could jump into
the pool that you could jump into that's
like when you swim it moves in the scene
you know yeah the same of course with an
infinity gene which is like it's going
up
let's get gold outside tastes like the
options in clothes but is this like
secret part on the on the side with an
outdoor above-ground like them and this
is like sky rocks right so like you're
going out and you're you got 360 view
and the water squishing back he goes
from against it that'd be pretty cool a
direct phone lines of Batman would also
be very cool that would be an essential
part of an ideal room that's pretty good
that's a good start
that's a good start I feel like I'd need
a teleportation somewhere or or just
like I could jump into a tube when it's
like transports me somewhere that'd be
really good I see a huge room but no no
but it's all going to be condensed like
everything else you'll notice you think
you can lose a lot of weight your bone
your cheek bone is very it's showing a
lot okay you should be a Clinton okay
okay oh my god yeah you lost too much
weight too much whele you know what
happened okay next what Pitts did you
have while you're growing up your dogs
what do we work like other dogs when mom
bought it won't last for one season okay
running cattle when I want to find I was
living like 503 it's like turn lane boy
Lane streets it's like right our house
is right by this v main street every
kind like almost every s I'm not here
I'm not letting your mom babysit join no
cuz those dogs do not deny my pets like
side in Canada
hey baby man they got run over my car
what takes too much of your time I avoid
you know I'm in charge of my time so I
think cat ability for the thing to think
up to mention my time I would say
driving driving to gets too much of my
time
I don't like gyrate taking people up
driving people places it's also because
it's hard to be productive while driving
can't do anything else while I'm driving
Essex it's up talking people on the
phone to play use the phone anything
else I don't mind so much because I can
usually get work done I can do something
I could be productive when I'm driving I
can't the fathers what are some small
things that make your day better and so
making everything anticipated driving
and creepy donut ten and seven five
minutes okay you get to spend time with
your wife only on the way they're doing
yeah when you get to sit down with your
dog on the way back I have to talk to
the whole day well he was sleeping
during the thing okay next that's it you
only think the only thing that makes
your day better is when I Drive you to
the select nice some nothing so this is
some of it all right okay okay question
for funny witty guys what shows are you
in - what show - my interview we'll
finish it the TV shows so together we're
watching Game of Thrones we're watching
east of shield
oh yeah blind spot we went to that went
to Gotham we went to suits they went
little arrow flash we watch like one
show a night one episode of net feels
like I've gone to so much stuff arrow
flash and then me I also watch billions
in Silicon Valley
tell me none you doesn't watch them I
did every now and then like a backup
shark tank or the profit if the proper
was good - yeah I like
Marcus ammonia okay last question oh my
god I better be a good one last question
what are you interested in that most
people haven't heard of it yeah I got
back here so excited my life sir you
just pick another one
the chatter dancing what's up in Chinese
what do you use those Chinese that you
watch Chinese TV shows i watch i watch a
lot of chinese TV show when Evans not
gullible b10
there's a lot of stuff a lot of Chinese
boxes arrive often that was yeah that
was also [ __ ] up for years some random
clothes showing up
well ste do that most people haven't
heard of I don't think most people heard
of bachata dancing come on you guys on
the Muppet chat again Smith maybe he's
on the dancing okay we'll go with the
chatter dancing
laughs gushing for me last question for
me what do you got Nina I like this one
if you are addicted of a small island
nation what crazy dictator stuff would
you do
I like the office one I'm excited for my
infinity edge pool auto motion out into
the city might recommend abacus Batman
what piece of entertainment do you wish
you could erase from your mind so that
you could experience what the first time
again oh wow
what was a great first expensi that the
experience often is around the
circumstances - I don't want to
experience it again if I could just
erase it from my mind that'd be great
but then I have to experience it again
for the first time so see the problem is
a lot of the first time you know it's a
good experience you can't recreate those
circumstance I need you let me ask
another one what really I was thinking
about that one maybe you could come back
maybe not only looks a live question
okay you going to switch it up what
movie title best describes your life
what movie title best describes my life
by you laughing - just a movie called
believe got to be able to cope believe
that's an easy one I'm curious you guys
what movie title best subscribes me or
this channel you and I know but just ask
you me I know it's a it's an interactive
thing here the Bourne Identity
ago the board identity boy are you
suctioning it in the camera
my wife the clown Jason what yeah I
don't know I picked that one
what the boy I have no idea I just don't
know I picked that one I watched it the
other day when I was sick the newest one
there you go the Bourne Identity all
right you guys watching if you had to
pick a movie title to describe this
channel
who is it what is it you can count below
thank you guys so much for watching go
be having an amazing weekend let us know
what you think about this new
spur-of-the-moment kind of video for
length with us we believe in you hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you know one word is much love
guys we'll see you soon